let's just bring in some breaking news
for you coming out of Moscow we can
cross over actually to dorsa Jabari our
correspondent their door so we're
hearing news of a very uh interesting
statement being made uh by the
president's spokesman regarding if any
pregosian's death
that's right so hell we've just been
hearing from Dmitry pescal
Scott person who is uh being making
comments about the death of the 62 year
old head of the mercenary group known as
the Wagner group peskov was asked
whether or not about the reports that
the Russian President Vladimir Putin had
something to do with progosian's death
and peskov responded by saying all of
this is an absolute lie and then he went
on to say that this the Wagner group as
a structure does not exist that it is
just that a group Dimitri peskov also
said that he can't comment about the
future of the Wagner group and the
organization he doesn't know anything
about how this group will continue to
move forward past the death of Evgeni
pagosian he also said that in order to
confirm pragosian's death they have to
wait for the expert examination exams to
be finished and that includes a number
of genetic testing that is going to be
taking place
um that there's still no official
results yet from the investigative
committee also important I think to note
that he was asked whether or not
Vladimir Putin will attend the funeral
of Evgeni pagosian and academ said that
it is impossible to discuss this at the
moment because the Russian president has
a very full schedule
he did although point out the one thing
peskov said that was also interesting is
that the Wagner group has made big
contributions to the so-called special
military operation the Russian military
is carrying out in Ukraine
um and that's also the Russian president
has not met evgeny pragosian in the past
few weeks he hadn't they had the two men
had not met lately as he put it well
that's the latest of course we'll
continue to monitor events coming out of
Moscow with yidoso Jabari there for us
thank you